muy buenas noches
pueblo paraguayo muy buenas noches
Pueblo Colorado
Quiero agradecer a los miles de
paraguayos y paraguayas que en estas
largas jornadas nos entregaron sus
sueños que confiaron en este proyecto
conciliador y patriótico que depositaron
en nuestras manos sus esperanzas para
que mañana podamos estar mejor y vamos a
estar mejor
[Aplausos]
querido compatriotas
hay una frase maravillosa de una canción
que cantamos siempre y que explican tres
líneas lo que vamos a respetar lo que
vamos a abrazar y lo que vamos a
combatir
la democracia es mi bandera pero con pan
porque es mentira la miseria la libertad
Gracias mi querido partido Colorado
vamos a honrarte hasta el último segundo
de nuestra gestión
Muchas gracias
mi querido
presidente de la asociación nacional
republicana Horacio Manuel cartes Jara
[Aplausos]
Horacio
admiro la Inmensidad de tu calificada
obstinación por la suerte del partido
Colorado
aquella vez rescatandolo de la llanura
esta vez uniendo a la familia colorada
fortaleciendo sus frentes y refundando
el concepto de partido al Servicio del
Hombre libre tu aporte presidente no se
paga sino con la moneda del respeto del
aprecio y lava la oración Gracias por
esta Victoria colorada Gracias por esta
Victoria paraguaya
[Aplausos]
Muchas gracias
a quien Hoy podemos decir es el más
ganador de todos los jefes de campaña de
la historia del Paraguay
ser jefe de campaña de un presidente es
de por sí ya un gran logro vos lo
hiciste en tres oportunidades José
Alberto alderete
tu serenidad tu capacidad de trabajo sin
límite y tu pasión por la política y por
el partido Colorado son un patrimonio
del partido y del país Muchas gracias
José Alberto
agradezco a los apoderados generales del
partido Eduardo González
Magnolia Mendoza y wildo almirón y todo
el equipo de apoderados miembros de mesa
gente de logística la gente de nuestro
centro de cómputos y a todos nuestros
gran equipo que hoy se puso el país al
hombro para que esto sea una fiesta
democrática
tengo la fortuna de decir que he visto
ese gesto de buena gente y buen Colorado
en muchos correligionarios con los que
competimos en diciembre y represento a
todos ellos en el querido Arnoldo vince
[Aplausos]
Qué grande ha sido tu aporte Arnoldo
gracias por ese capítulo de unidad
colorada que por lo ir por lo visto
leímos juntos vos y yo de la doctrina
del comportamiento Colorado Muchas
gracias Arnoldo
gratitud a una persona ejemplar
y a un político con probidad en
mayúscula
mi copiloto mi amigo y hermano en esta
carrera llena de emociones
en esta calle en esta carrera llena de
emociones obstáculos Y a veces tropiezo
pero siempre con la felicidad
republicana Gracias querido señor dice
presidente de la República del Paraguay
Pedro Hércules Adriana gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi querido mangui Pili estará feliz allá
arriba mirando hoy a su hermano
vicepresidente
[Aplausos]
Quiero agradecer a mi familia por ser mi
sostén a lo largo de mi vida y
principalmente en estos dieciocho meses
de campaña Quiero agradecer a mis padres
que me han inculcado valores principios
que me han llenado de amor a la vida a
la familia y que hoy siguen siendo un
farol hacia donde trabajar por un país
mejor para todos los paraguayos a mis
hermanos a mis amigos
todos quienes han confiado y han creído
siempre en mí
en mis hijos Gonzalo constanza seres
Muchas gracias por ser el sostén que
permite que nuestro equipo siempre
funcione
[Aplausos]
a mi esposa a mi compañera a mi amiga
aquella que confió en un joven de 17
años que no ofrecía mucho futuro
tengo que permitió gracias al trabajo al
poder del amor a la fe y el saber que
juntos no hay desafío que no podamos
enfrentar Gracias Lety
[Aplausos]
querido correligionarios apreciados
compatriotas
vamos a desterrar el fatalismo de que
estamos condenados a nuestro presente
nosotros somos los dueños de nuestro
propio destino de nuestro futuro y de
nuestro Porvenir yo les digo no le vamos
a defraudar nos vamos a defraudar el
sacrificio de los correligionarios y las
correligionarias que son los guardianes
de la voluntad popular que cuidaron cada
voto para que se respete a rajatabla la
libre decisión Del soberano
imposible cuantificar mi gratitud solo
puedo decirle Gracias infinitas gracias
por su esfuerzo y su dedicación
hoy no Estamos celebrando un triunfo
personal hoy Estamos celebrando la
victoria de un pueblo que con su voto
eligió el camino de la paz social del
diálogo de la fraternidad y de la
reconciliación nacional un pueblo que
envió un claro mensaje de que los
agravios el odio y la rencillas no son
el camino
[Aplausos]
a los que creyeron en otros proyectos le
digo que más allá de los de los colores
partidarios que levantan falsas murallas
somos hijos e hijas de una madre común
la patria paraguaya esa patria reclama
lo mejor de cada uno de nosotros y en
esa gran empresa nacional todos estamos
moralmente obligados a ejercer un papel
en el lugar que nos toque solo así
podemos enfrentar con éxito la pobreza
la corrupción y la impunidad
desde mañana empezaremos a diseñar el
Paraguay que Todos queremos sin groseras
desigualdades ni injustas asimetrías
sociales tenemos mucho por hacer después
de los últimos años de estancamiento
económico de déficit fiscal con un
preocupante índice desocupados y el
aumento de la pobreza extrema la tarea
que nos espera no es para una sola
persona o solo para un partido
convoco a la unidad y al consenso para
alcanzar nuestro destino de bienestar
colectivo y de prosperidad sin
exclusiones ha llegado el tiempo de
postergar nuestras diferencias para
priorizar las causas comunes que nos
unen como nación ante todo y sobre todo
somos paraguayos
ese tiene que ser el único distintivo
que nos identifique como protagonistas
del Gran proyecto de esta restauración
moral de recuperación económica de
crecimiento inclusivo y de Justicia
social viva el Paraguay
viva el partido Colorado